we knew they wanted to start a new
chapter and now the date is set with the
palace confirming Harry and Megan will
begin their new life of financial
independence on the 31st of March with
no office at Buckingham Palace they are
going out on their own I think it will
be very exciting the beginning because
Megan have been absolutely desperate to
leave the royal family for the moment
she joined it seems in retrospect and
Prince Harry is very happy to be with
her but I think the reality will be
quite harsh in January the media had
gathered in Sandringham as the Royals
met to thrash out how it was going to
work but after the Queen confirmed that
she had allowed the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex to step away from royal duties
her grandson made it clear he wasn't
entirely happy we're now told that he
will get to keep his honorary military
titles but he won't perform any official
duties for them in the next 12 months
they will remain the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex but will not use their HRH styles
the couple will return to the UK for six
engagements between the end of February
and the start of March and what they can
use the Royal in their Sussex royal
brand is still under review with
suggestions the Queen has already ruled
it out the complexities around all of
this are summed up by the fact that
there is no precedent for this kind of
working model all the way that Harry and
Megan want to be financially independent
so it means in 12 months time there is
going to be a review of how it's all
working not just for the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex but also the impact
it's having on the wider royal family
the Queen who was back at work today
described last year as having bumpy
times 2020 got off to a turbulent start
with Harry and Megan's announcement but
also the ongoing questions for Prince
Andrew about his links with convicted
sex offender Jeffrey Epstein which meant
that his 60th birthday celebrations
while marked with bells at Westminster
Abbey and a post on the royal Twitter
account was more low-key than you might
usually expect
I'm very sorry to see him in this
situation
but there'll be no place for him in
public life and no real role within the
royal family unless he deals with this
Jeffrey Epstein fair there is now some
clarity around Harry and Megan's future
like last year they'll attend the
Commonwealth Day service on the 9th of
March they may be leaving the working
firm but the Queen has made it clear
they are still valued members of the
family Rhiannon Mills Sky News